not only does it encourage you to read
it tells you how many verses you've read
how many pages you read how long you've
been on it and best of all the hasanah
counter download the qurani app now and
have a ramadan with allah subhanahu wa
tala's book like you've never had before
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh brothers and sisters in the
efforts friends hope you guys are
wearing each other so as you guys may
know crypt and conan i don't personally
know them uh i did kind of
come across them or hear about them
after passing away of their cousin cadet
um and mail up mercy on him in this
video he which was sent to me he said
something interesting he's been
interviewed by a lady
and he mentioned something weird
something very strange and ajib
happening when he was signing a contract
when he just made it
uh i mean the perspective that we're
talking about let's watch inshallah and
see what was that weird occurrence that
happened
so it's like yeah the grime thing was
here for five minutes so we think they
deserve this and then when we're sitting
down with the the lawyer the lawyers
like sign it
sign it don't matter where it's just
sign it because they're not signing no
one just take the check take the money
just sign it like he it was a bit
pressurish and i'm like why is he like
pressuring me like that like i didn't
really like that and i'll be honest i've
never told this story before
and i feel like i like
i'm just gonna say it because i feel
like
you should know anyway when we signed it
before we signed a door i was a bit off
on it
and because the pressure was a bit much
was that signing signing and i remember
speaking to my old manager right and
didn't know if i'm lying i'm flying he's
po he's he's phoned me and we're in the
shooter and i put my loudspeaker old
manager i like that if i'm nine i'm
flying i don't know what that means but
it sounds so sick but let's carry on and
he's like yeah like well you're not
thinking about it though we're like yeah
we want to sign it but we want to wait
and see what happens and
like on quad chamber his voice changed
in like like a demon's voice
sign the deal silent now sign it silent
i got so sugar from my phone on the
floor
if i'm lying i'm flying well i
i mean crept was staring at the phone on
the floor like what the his voice just
changed into like a gremlin and all he
kept saying sign the deal sign the deal
sign the deal and i'm like what
like i dropped the phone and stepped
back like this and we're just staring at
the phone for about three minutes like
i'm like did you hear that bro he's like
yeah bro like what the [ __ ] is that like
that's mad
so i picked up the phone and i phoned
back
my manager like yo bro like what
happened to your voice bro is that what
are you talking about so oh your voice
changed bro is that what we talking
about
so from then i was a bit
yeah yeah this is a bit funny ended up
signing the door anyway but i was like
five hours late they still signed it i
was a bit skeptical if you watched the
video back
my face is a bit like yeah
it's a bit weird i don't know if i'm oh
i was over thinking okay a few things to
get here number first first thing
uh if i'm lying i'm flying i like that
my phone wouldn't be using that yeah
okay that's quite interesting
um jokes aside though uh one thing he
mentions now when he's talking about
this so
now
we can say you know what some people are
rational like i'm not rational but you
know people like oh no they could have
been they know somebody's speaking to
someone and the voice starts the signal
goes funny and then they start sounding
like a gremlin
argument said let's address both let's
suppose the voice went funny because of
a signal connection and it sounded like
a demon
regardless the industry that they're in
is a satanic industry like let's just
let's just be real you know is it
anything let me say it i'm not saying
that satan worshipers no it's not
necessarily but is there anything that
is in there that'll bring it closer to
the religion bring it closer to the god
god consciousness no so regardless if
it's sounded or not but
even if we look at it from an angle
where we believe in the unseen which is
the jinn and shaytan etc it's possible
it's possible they want you to sign it
why because that's going to lead you
further astray now crept and conan like
i said before they are fellow believers
yeah yes they may commit certainty etc
and i'm not trying to lighten the sin
i'm not trying to make it seem like nice
calm no i'm not seeing that what i'm
trying to say is no matter what sin
you're committing carry on praying
yourself about krypton conan carrying a
salah
people say they see in the masjid carry
on i don't care what since you're
committing brother you carry on going
you carry on doing your bit don't ever
think i'm sinning i'm doing this no no
no no because i think the starting point
where maybe you going down this route is
because shaytan wanted you you know and
you say to yourself we still signed it
because it might be the fact that before
this interview he was talking about your
life that it was really really hard for
you et cetera you know your stepdad and
i think about killed or something along
those lines etc and he was in a
distressed moment et cetera i understand
sometimes what happens is we don't have
enough tobacco in allah believe me
allah's created heavens and the earth
allah has created the universe
and the billions of creatures in it it
is not hard for allah for you to give
you a better way out than the music
industry but we will fall short
sometimes we have our talking in the
world the affairs and we're like no you
know there's a way out for me i need to
make it et cetera you may have taken
that puff it still doesn't make you a
bad person yes you're sinning with
awesomeness the point that i'm trying to
make here is that look having trust in
allah's ki because you was in a
crossroad and you had this record label
thing essentially inside your videos
went viral etc so it's like the
temptation of the dunya got the best of
you it all happens don't ever feel that
you cannot come out of it and we also
lost the power of talent to guide you
and myself and everybody as well in
charlotte yeah so i just wanted to make
that clear one thing that i like is that
a lot of people might say they just
saying it for the sake of it like you
know some not all like you know somalis
you'd like to say well like be like to
like i think it's a good thing you know
why because there's a scholar who said
it is more beloved to me that a person
may lie and say wallahi or ok
or
then a person who is a mushrik who takes
off by his deity and tells the truth
listen carefully it is more beloved to
me and i think this makes perfect sense
and it's tahit that obviously line is
haram we shouldn't but it is more
beloved that somebody says
and he's lying it is better than someone
saying i swear by my cow god uh
and he's telling the truth yeah it's
like for example allah talks about in
the quran for those when the
the the sahaba attacked the caravan and
they said i was the holy month he said
it may have been the holy month but what
they're doing and the mushriks are doing
is worse so what we're seeing is in this
very instance that it is good that he
has the he takes him off by allah so i'm
just saying that in a nutshell just to
wrap up brothers and sisters is that
very very important having tawan allah
and put your trust in allah so you do
not fall for the
fame and the money and the glory at the
cost of signing your life away sometimes
because you might be going and thinking
no i'm just doing music okay music is
not permissible except whatever it may
be but then the things that you're going
to do they might get you to say you know
when you're doing a track do a sign you
don't know what the sign is you might
decide to satanic so the industry is
corrupt within itself so in a nutshell
this is what i wanted to share with you
guys brothers and sisters let's be
conscious in uh allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala's uh
who allah is and his tawak and he's the
one that provides you everything i have
to go out my way this is the biggest
tricks we all do with our marriage with
our business with our friendship with
our entire life we think we need to take
matters into our own hands because as if
allah is not performing no you're not
performing you do your bit you fix your
effects with allah allah
and just before i finish it reminds me
of the companion or the prophet peace be
upon him who used to drink alcohol and
the sahabas used to tell him not to do
it not to do it until one day he used to
drink alcohol imagine in front of the
prophet sallallahu and this is a
companion who went to the war like
et cetera you know he's performed as
well
in that aspect and one day i think
he said may allah curse you and the
prophet salam stopped him the protestant
didn't say he's an alcoholic he's this
is that he said don't say him don't say
don't curse him because indeed he loves
allah and his messenger so even people
may be sinning and doing zinna and alco
ariba or this that do not take away the
love of god they might have
just because they're in that sin and
once again we ask allah to keep us firm
and away from inshallah and we make dua
our brothers krept and conan inshallah
they know what they're doing we don't
want to get into detail that god allah
guides him guides us inshallah until
next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi wabaraka